네, 안녕하세요. 어, 빌사남이
간다. 어, 제가 또 이번에
드라이브스를 좀 준비했는데 오늘은
신사동을 한번 쭉 돌아볼 거예요.
그래서 신사동에 뭐 최근 매각된
사례라든지 요즘 임대 사례라든지 좀
특징 있는 건물들 어, 그런 것들
한번 좀 저랑 돌아보면서 좀 생생하게
제가 아는 정보들을 여러분들한테
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 저는 지금
학동 사거리 앞에 나와 있고요.
그래서 지금 저쪽 부분이 이제 다
이제 신사동이에요. 어, 일단은 학동
사거리랑 그 앞구정 로데오 역으로
좀 지나갈 예정이에요. 일단은
신사동에서 가장 좋은 곳이 어디야
하면은 저는 앞구정 로데오라고 생각을
합니다. 그리고 특히 악구정 로데오
역 근처보다는 그 도상공원 인근
그러니까 이제 뭐 런던 베이을 있는
쪽 어 그쪽 길이 저는 제일 좋다라고
생각하고 매매도 워낙 좀 뭐 최고가로
계속 좀 거래가 되고 있고 임대도
되게 잘되고 있습니다. 그래서 임대료
수준도 되게 높고 그래서 최근에 임대
맞춘게 평당 임대료가 얼마냐면 무려
100만 원이 넘습니다. 100만
원이 넘어요. 이면인데도 불구하고
지금 그 런던 베이을 잇는 그쪽 길
어 도상공원 접하고 있는 그쪽 길이
임대 수준도 높고 어 되게 많은
업체들이 찾고 있다 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같아요. 근데 여러분들이 아셔야
될게 지금 제가 뭐 100만 원
이렇게 말씀드린게 대부분 다 통임대
기준이에요. 그래서 개별 임대는 사실
그렇게까지 맞추기가 어렵거든요.
근데 통임대 같은 경우에는 비싼
임대료를 주고라도 임차인들이 많이
들어오려고 합니다. 통임대 메리트가
되게 많아요. 그래서 건물 전체를
쓴다라는 거는 업체를 홍보하기에도
되게 좋거든요. 그래서 업체들
입장에서 봤을 때는 어 물론 이제
매장으로 돈을 버는 것도 있겠지만
그렇게 통임대로 들어와서 고객들한테
이렇게 홍보를 하기 위한 목적으로
비싼 임대료를 주고 또 많이 들어오는
경우도 많습니다. 그래서 뭐 저희
회사 같은 경우에도 저희도 뭐 직접
다 통으로 쓰고 있지만 어 직접 다
쓰고 있는 거에 대한 메리트가 되게
크거든요. 네. 그렇게 통임대가
들어왔을 때 그 런던 베이글을 인근에
100만 원 넘는 그렇게 임대
사례들이 좀 생겨나고 있습니다. 올해
4월 달에 이제 두 개 다 맞췄는데
최근에 어 100만 원 넘게
맞췄습니다. 네.
그래서 사실 요쪽 지금 런던 베이을
잇는이 도로랑 그다음에 우리가 이제
알고 있던 그 앞구정이라고 불리는 그
좀 도로 더 넓은 그 일방 통행길에
뭐 지금 상황으로 제가 봤을 때는
여기 런던 베이글 있는 쪽이 더
좋아요. 임대료 수준도 그렇고
업체들이 여기에 되게 비싼 임대료로
좀 많이 들어가려고 합니다. 그 지금
여기가 이제 앞에가 이제 런던
베이글인데 여기 좌측에 이제 건물
신축한 것도 통임들 임대를 맞췄어요.
네. 그래서 요것도 맞췄고 그다음에
런던 베이글을 옆에 것도 맞췄고
그다음에 저쪽에 이제 코너에 있는 어
저기도 임대를 맞췄습니다. 그리고
지금 이쪽 길 딱 그 도상공원 딱
바로 앞에 있는 요쪽 건물들도 어
계속 최고가로 거래가 되고 있고 뭐
2억 5천 뭐 최대 거의 3억까지 어
거래가 된 사례들이 있습니다. 그리고
여기도 통임대에는 임대료 수준이 되게
높아요. 최근에 이제 런던 베이그를
팔려고 내놨는데
지금 한 2,억 정도의 얘기 중이라고
합니다. 원래 3,억에 내놨는데 좀
조정을 해서 지금 2,억 정도의 진행
중으로 알고 있어요. 그냥 예컨데
이제 그렇게 홍보를 좀 해 가지고 어
일단 매각을 좀 돕기 위해서
이거 넣어도 되나 모르겠다. 그래서
어찌 됐든 지금 2,억에 지금 진행
중으로 알고 있고 요쪽에 좀 분위기가
있어요. 사실 강남구에
어 이렇게 좀 공원 앞에 이렇게
매장을 낼 만한 공간이 좀 많이 없긴
하는데 어 여기는 그 도상 공원에
대한 느낌이 되게 많아요. 그리고
요것도 지금 통임대 맞췄거든요. 이미
다 맞췄습니다. 이것도 되게 좀 높은
가격에 어 맞췄고 그 명품리처럼
우선적으로 몇 년 계약을 하고 뭐
그런게 맞나요? 그렇죠. 그래서 뭐
다 장기 계약 돼 있죠. 그래서 앞서
설명드렸던 건물들도 기본 다 5년
이상 계약했고 제일 많이 계약한게
아까 사례 중에 한 15년 계약한
것도 있어요. 그래서 그만큼 장기
계약으로 계약을 되게 오랫동안
합니다. 방금 보여 드렸던 그쪽 길만
좀 임대 수준이 되게 높고 도로만
조금 옆에 가도 확 달라집니다. 저도
딱 보면서 아 이게 진짜 도로 하나
끼고 임대료 수준이라든지 임대료가
이렇게 많이 차이 나는구나. 어 네.
이런 생각을 좀 많이 하게 되는데
그렇게 도로 하나라도
좀 이렇게 차이가 많이 난다라는 거
알고 계시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고
여기가 이제 그 도상공원 앞에
리버사이드 길이라고 하는데 여기 뭐
에르메스랑 막 여기 명품 업체들 많이
들어왔죠. 그래서 여기도 뭐 임대료
수준뿐만 아니라 가격도 굉장히 비싼
곳입니다. 그다음에 저기 이마룡 씨
건물도 있고 그다음에 저쪽으로 가면
이제 박서준 씨 건물도 있고 그래서
연예인분들도 굉장히 좀 관심 있어
하는 어 이임 이마룡 씨인데요.
지나가네 그죠 그죠 진짜가요 진짜요
제 못 받았는데 건물로 가시나
봅니다. 그 기사 아마 여러분들
보셨을 텐데 예전에 그 4억인가
사셨대요. 건물. 그래 가지고 지금
어 몇백억이 올랐다고 뭐 이런
기사들도 좀 놨었는데 이마룡 씨여
저기 여기서 좀 많이 마주치는 거
같아요.
어찌됐든 그 악구정 로데오 쪽은 그
도상공원이 저는 되게 크다라고
보거든요. 근데 여기 같은 경우에는
일반적인 상권도 다 비슷비슷하잖아요.
업종도 그렇고. 근데 이제 도상공원은
도상공원을 끼고 있는 그쪽 블록 같은
경우에는 어 다른 지금 요쪽 블록을
대체할 만한 데가 저는 없다라고
생각하거든요. 그러니까 악고정
로데오가
똑같았어요. 그니까 너무 안
좋았었어요. 근데 이제 공통적으로
했던게 임대료를 낮췄습니다. 임대료를
다 낮춘 다음에 그런 플레이어들이
들어올 수 있게끔 만들어 가지고
어떻게 보면 살아났다라고
생각하거든요. 여기가 이제 세로
스킬이거든요. 새로 스길은 그래도
사람이 조금 있어요. 네. 조금 있고
주말에는 꽤 많습니다. 그다음에 여기
시장 앞에 어 시장 앞에 여기 강남
상가 아파트 있는 쪽 요쪽에도 사람이
꽤 있어요. 주말에도 꽤 많더라고요.
그다음에 여기 대로변 쪽 보면은
도산대로 쪽에 그 성영액과가
많잖아요.
그래서 성용액과 원장님들이 건물을 또
많이 샀어요. 성영액과 원장님들이
대부분
뭐 대출이 되게 잘 나와요. 그래서
대출을 좀 이용해 가지고 건물을 좀
많이 샀고
운전을 되게 잘하시네요.
제 그래도 좁은 길을
운전 출신입니다. 운전 출신이고
레토나를 몰았어요. 예전에
장교분들 운전이고
저기 앞에 이제 대빵오락실 있는 쪽
요쪽도
요쪽에도 밤에 사람이 진짜 많아 지금
시간에 좀 없는데 그래서 지금 여기
느낌이랑 그 가로 스킬 느낌이랑은 좀
달라요. 그래가지고 제가 제가 만약에
지금 여기를 살려야 되는 사람이라고
생각하면 일단 여기를 와야 될 이유를
만들어 줘야 되거든요. 그니까 이제
컨텐츠를 넣어야 되는데 대형 이런
업체들이 들어와 있는 그냥 단순히
그런 데가 아니라 사람들이 경험을
그니까 지금 성수동에 이제 사람들이
왜 많냐면
일단은 뭐 서울숲도 있지만 그 거기서
사람들이 와서 경험을 많이 그니까
팝업 스토어 워낙 지금 유명해져
가지고
사람들 저희도 실제로 팝업을 해
봤지만 거기 이제 그런 경험을 하려고
많이 오거든요. 어찌 됐든 거기서
홍보를 할 수 있으니까 되게 높은
임대료인데도 불구하고 막 들어오는
거예요. 차라리 그냥 마케팅 비용을
쓰는 거예요. 회사 홍보하려고.
그래서 뭔가 성수동은 그 팝업
스토어가 뜬게 영행을 저는 좀 많이
줬다라고 생각을 합니다. 필사람도
팝업을 성공적으로 잘했잖아요.
그러니까요. 그래서 그거 하면서 느낀
적이 많았어요.
또 사실 의향이 있어.
다음에도 상황 밤에 뭐 사람들이 되게
많이 궁금해했었고
꽤 많은 사람들이 왔었어요. 거의 막
2,명 넘게 왔으니까. 그리고 저기
이제 현대 아파트죠. 그래서 저는
여기 좀 악구정 현대가 좀 빨리
재건축이 됐으면 좋겠습니다.
근데 실현 가능성이 몇 %로 보시는
거? 뭐 여기 신현대가 제일 빠른데
신현대는 뭐 금방 내 9년대는 근데
시간이 좀 오래 걸릴 것 같아요.
왜냐면 여기 일단은 전에도 제가
말씀드렸지만 이해 관계인이 많아요.
그러니까 상가 같은 경우에도 다 자게
쪼개져 있고 그거를 다 동의하는
데까지가 시간이 많이 걸립니다. 최소
50년 정도 걸리는 50년 그 전에
되지 않을까요? 지금 우리 GDP가
어 그때 당시에 뭐 1900 뭐
70년도 막 이때 수준으로 지어 놓은
거에서 좀 빨리 이게 재건축이 됐으면
좋겠어요. 그래서 진짜 멋있는 집이
나왔으면 좋겠습니다. 예. 진짜
럭셔리하고 그리고 진짜 펜트하우스
같은 경우에는 진짜 1천억 넘는 그런
집들이 좀 나왔으면 좋겠고 실제로
나올 것 같아요. 실제 조감도대로 안
되는 경우가 되게 많더라고
하더라고요. 만약에 조감도가 잘
나온다고 해도 괜찮게 뽑힐까요?
그거는 모르죠.
청남동이야 뭐 거긴 이제 공사비도
그렇고 뭐 어쩔 수 없이 해가지고
그렇게 되는데 여기 뭐 어떻게 될지
모르겠지만 뭐 조합장이 어떻게
하느냐에 따라서 또 달라지기도 하고
뭐 지켜봐야겠지만
여기 한양은 어떤가요? 한양 여기
너무 좋죠. 이게 지금
한양이었나? 뭐 평당 2억 찍었다고
막 기사 났었는데 여기 이제 마지막
이제 악구정 로데오 역 쪽이고 지금
행정구역상가 어디인가요? 여기가 이제
악구정동이고 여기가 신사동이에요. 아
지금 역 사이로 지금 왼쪽 오른쪽이
나눠진거 예 그렇죠.
그리고 여기 앞에 보이는이 전면 긴
거 있잖아요.
요게 800억에 팔렸습니다. 연면적이
300평이 조금 안 되는데 여기
보이시죠?
이 안에 뭐가 들어온 거지? 그리고
마지막으로 이제 제가 갈 곳은 저기
하나에서 매입을 했는데 두 개 건물을
매입을 했어요. 파이브 가이즈 들어와
가지고 지금 매장 운영 중이고 그
옆에도 아이스크림 가게 들어와 가지고
운영하고 있습니다. 여기
여기깁니다.요
두 건물을 매입했습니다. 파이브
가이즈.
그래서 두 개 다 해서 매입 금액이
800억이 넘어요. 근데 저는
개인적인 생각인데 5가이즈
관계자분들이
뭐 보실 수 있겠는데 전 개인적으로
어 쉐네
그래서 일단 좀 이렇게 드라이브스로를
좀 돌아봤는데
정말 이거는 리얼 대본 없이 그냥 막
찍는 거예요. 근데 막 찍는 거여서
이게 좀 정신없이 썼긴 했는데 어
여러분들 좀 어 도움이 되셨을지
모르겠습니다. 가능성이 안 좋으면
여기까지
[음악]